Hey good afternoon and welcome to the
promise of an async future awaits which
I've gotten kudos for for being the most
interesting talk title and I got all the
important keywords in the title or
diamond no so the story behind this talk
is C sharp has had a sink and a weight
and tasks of tasks of T and this task
based asynchronous programming model
since version 5 now I work on the dotnet
docs team and I am primarily responsible
for everything related to c-sharp we
thought we had a bit of a problem in
terms of we really didn't think
developers understood this model
particularly well so we started tracking
issues on that and we made a project on
our repo for everything related to a
weight async task task of t continue
with when all when any and wait all
weight any and all that I would you
started collecting the issues that came
in based on articles about those and
based on those concepts this project has
more issues than any other sub area of
dotnet that we write about so clearly we
have not explained it extremely well
that's where this talk is growing grown
out of is I'm taking all these issues
and we're going to redo a lot of the
documentation around this concept
because we think we made it harder than
it had to be we think the concepts
aren't as hard we think the language
itself put some very nice features in
play for you to do asynchronous
programming and we've struggled to
explain it well and to give a mental
model that will work so the arc of this
talk what we're going to do is we're
going to imagine something that we do
every day or pretty close to everyday
describe it to another human the way we
would describe it look at how a computer
would actually execute those steps and
point out that that's really isn't what
we want then we'll start to talk about
what asynchronous means in terms of how
we want to make this
work and what would that do to our code
to make it execute the way we want it to
be done and yet still be able to
describe it in a way that is crystal
clear and then in the last 15 or 20
minutes I'm going to expand on what Mads
had talked about yesterday
and things that are coming in c-sharp
ate and talked about async streams which
takes these concepts and moves them a
little bit into the kind of things that
we're doing now that have data sources
that are bringing us data from another
place and they come in batches and so on
and we want to be able to work with
those in a good way
so here's the analogy that we're going
to do we're gonna make breakfast which
is a task all of us know how to do and
we've described it to others so what are
we going to do I'm gonna make an
American breakfast because when I
started to research and put it together
for this talk here I learned that an
English breakfast means something
different in different places so I
didn't want to get sidetracked I said
okay we'll do an American breakfast I'm
going to pour a cup a coffee first
because before I get coffee I'm not
doing anything at least I'm not gonna do
anything successfully so when you pour
cup of coffee
I want to fry two eggs I want to have
three slices of bacon I'm going to toast
two pieces of bread I'm gonna add butter
and jam to the bread once it's toasted
and then I'm gonna pour orange juice and
now I'll sit down and eat now if I were
to write that in code it looks a lot
like this out of the way I'm going to
pour my coffee put it in a coffee object
I'm going to fry the eggs after that
stun we're gonna fry the bacon I'm gonna
toast the bread I'm going to apply the
butter I'm gonna ply the jam I'm going
to pour the OJ everything's ready I'm
gonna sit down and eat this is a very
clear description of what we're doing
it reads one step after the other it's
exactly what happens now if I execute
this code the way it runs okay for
coffee warming up the egg pan I've got
the eggs in there the eggs are ready I
put the bacon on
now I flip the bacon now the bacons done
I put toast in the toaster but the jam
on poured the OJ and breakfast is ready
now I sorted a lot of the time outs
there because nobody wants to just watch
that program run but you can see that
what happens is if I do it do those
steps exactly as this is written I'm not
really gonna be happy
did the eggs they're sitting on a plate
they're getting cold I'm watching the
bacon that's happening I'm doing the jam
I'm doing this and then finally ate when
we describe what we do to another human
when we describe these steps we take and
we describe this to another human we
describe them something like this it's
very linear this is what you do but that
other human who probably has some
experience in the kitchen and probably
cooks doesn't execute them like this
they're going to start warming up the
pan now I'm going to warm up the baking
pan and start the bacon you know
depending on how long I think each part
takes after I flip the bacon I'm gonna
go over here I'm going to start the
toast I'm gonna come back watch the
bacon get that off get the bacon off
when it's totally done now the toast is
done put the butter and jam on and then
pour the BOJ so I'm doing these things
asynchronously even though I have
written the instruction in a synchronous
linear fashion that's the mental model
we want to have about asynchronous
programming in c-sharp I'm going to
write something that looks synchronous
and looks like it executes one after the
other and the compiler is going to do
some magic to rearrange how this code
executes so that it happens
asynchronously okay so that's the first
part of this mental model think about
the fact that what we're doing here is
nothing really special but really
translating instructions just like we
give another person into the actions
that they would take right we first
taught our kids to start cooking they
might do it something like this they
would stand there and just watch
something happen okay now it's ready for
the next step and they would stand there
and watch it as we get more experienced
we do it in a different way
so that's our steps now here's the next
thing that we did really bad when we
started to explain this and when we
started to even designing the api's and
to work with things asynchronous
programming might look a lot like
parallel programming because everyone
knows multi-threaded programming is hard
we started to think this must be hard
because this works the same way and we
have this mental model we're so often we
think that things are asynchronous means
parallel and it's doing something
different if I go back to these
instructions in this program if this
were to be parallel I would want
different cpus doing each one of those
steps or different threads doing each
one of those steps and they would be
synchronously waiting for something to
happen it would be like if I brought all
my family in to cook breakfast and our
youngest watches the toast and well
that's a little bit more experience and
it's done a little more cooking you work
with the eggs no I'll watch the bacon
and so on now let's think of the
difference in what that means
in terms of scale for what we want for
our programs what I really want is
something that's asynchronous one person
can be in the kitchen I'll start one
task and I'll go do something else until
I need to respond to something that
happened over here on this task and then
I'll come back and do that part I mean
while this one is doing something and I
can start something else I get a signal
when I reach a certain point right the
most obvious one is when I put bread in
the toaster and press the button toast
pops I can hear the toaster pop I know I
have to go do something else that's
asynchronous so now here's why we want
to really be explicit about which one of
these models we use suppose you're
building something that's a large-scale
web application that's going to be used
by thousands of people if I want to
scale it out by going parallel and I'm
going
have each CPU take a request do the
steps in order blocking on each one of
those that thread spends a lot of time
blocked and waiting as does every other
thread a request comes in thread does
something wait synchronously doing
nothing does something else
wait synchronously doing nothing and so
on what that means is as we get more and
more people accessing this website we
don't scale up very well because we've
got all these threats sitting there
going I'm waiting for something to
finish I can't respond to another
incoming request but if I correctly do
it asynchronously now what happens is
that one thread can start something oh
I'm going to need some data from a
database I'm gonna make a database call
ok I'm ready to handle another incoming
request so now I can get that request
and start doing something else until
it's off to the database or oh this data
came back from the database formulate
the page send the page back or send the
API call back so by being asynchronous I
get much much better scale out because I
keep those CPUs as busy as possible the
CPUs aren't sitting there waiting for
something to finish as they would if
this was asynchronous blocking operation
right so that's what we want to do we
want to take this and we're going to say
you know what I really can do this with
one cook I can make this happen more
quickly but I'm going to a synchronously
do it I'm going to start a task let that
task proceed and then we'll come back
when I get signaled and I will do some
extra work so that's our main key in
terms of how we're going to put this
together so now let's look at our code
here what I want to be able to do is I
need to change some of these steps so
that I can start something and then come
back and do more work later
all right so let's start with the eggs
because pouring coffee is a synchronous
operation nothing is happening until
they get to coffee so we'll keep that
synchronous
so we'll go to fry eggs all right I want
a signal that I'm doing something
asynchronously so I'm gonna end that
with the async suffix great I'm going to
change its signature to return a task of
eight and I'm getting some red squiggles
here where I return the egg so I need to
make this an async method great so I'm
telling the compiler to do things
asynchronously and return when we're
done I'm getting a green squiggle here
because right now I'm not actually
awaiting anything so internally in here
for this demonstration I just just start
with a synchronous version i
synchronously waited here I want to
await these so as part of this this
demonstration I did synchronously wait
don't do that
please don't that was a bad example this
is a better example if I want to have
something take some time I'm going to
wait I'm also not using thread dot sleep
which is code we've seen in the wild and
the reason thread that sleep as bad as
it does synchronously wait and that
thread stays blocked await task delay it
says all right in 3 seconds in this
instance start again okay so now I slide
on up to main and now you see that I
have a mismatch in what's getting
returned here I've got eggs this fry
eggs which is now fry eggs async it's
returning the wrong type I'm now
returning a task of egg so I need to
await it
and I'm getting red squiggles here
because I need to now make this an async
task of Maine there we go
and I think I already upgraded this
project so I should get a build good
zero warnings awesome so that's a
feature that was added in c-sharp seven
one is you can now make Maine an async
method must return must be easier must
return a task or a task of int so the
only things that can return so let's
finish this with these other tasks bacon
takes quite a while so frying the bacon
now we're gonna change its name to fry
bacon async I'm gonna do that as a
refactoring so it changes where it was
called once again I've got some
synchronous weights here
I want to await that bacon needs to get
cooked on both sides so we're going to
await it as well and this now is an
async method that returns a task of
bacon that's a good time to look at just
exactly what we think for an
asynchronous method and why some of the
syntax was chosen the way it does if I
squint a little bit I can think this is
still just returning bacon when it's
done my return statement is returned new
bacon I like that it's now async so it's
actual signature is async task of bacon
so the compiler is doing some magic for
me to make this result that I'm
returning
the result of the task so some work the
compiler does that that changes that so
that the signature matches what's
declared for the method but in my return
statement I'm actually just giving it
the the thing that is returned by the
task rather than the task itself and
once again will come up here I'm now
getting this warning that says you know
you you weren't waiting awaiting this
and it's really a task so we're going to
call this
oh wait task of bacon will do the same
thing with our bread we're going to
toast our bread asynchronously async
task of toast though there we go pretty
quick and simple refactorings not so
much that it takes very little time in
code to write differently but this still
looks like the same kind of code I can
still reason about its logic very
clearly and then oh wait squiggles are
all gone
life is good okay so I can reason about
this just by reading and I will await
this here okay so this looks good I like
this so some things I like about the
syntax and things that making this shift
from doing this synchronously we're how
we wrote it is exactly how it executes
to something that looks more
asynchronous it's a little bit more like
what we would do in real life but if I
do a little bit of a code review if we
take just one of the methods there's
only a couple changes to write an
asynchronous algorithm I put the async
modifier on the method I changed the
signature to make sure it's returning
something like a task and where I need
to I await something inside that method
okay that looks good I like that it
really isn't that hard I can squint and
I can still kind of go well if it were
synchronous it would look like this and
now if we look at the code that calls
that method
it looks very similar once again I'm
just starting these things I'm awaiting
them and then I move on with the rest of
the algorithm so we're part were there
this still looks pretty similar so if I
run it now I should be super happy my
breakfast everything should get done in
about the same time and I should eat
when it's ready wait a minute hmm this
is working the same way that's kind of a
bummer yes but it scales better so if I
were making 100 breakfasts this would
work better because as I've started
something and I'm awaiting it well I
could be starting someone else's
breakfast so I know as the gentleman up
here kind of pointed out if this were in
a web farm web kind of thing where where
I'm trying to respond to multiple
requests and lots of requests coming
quickly I can now do that this may be
enough in a lot of cases that's pretty
cool if this were a UI app and I wanted
to be trying to move things around and
interact with the window this would be
enough as well because now I've started
a task and while that task is doing its
thing the CPU can be doing other things
so in many scenarios this is all you
need but in this instance for this one
person trying to make breakfast I
haven't really done the simulation that
I want okay so the lesson so far let's
take a brief break and look at what
we've done we've added a couple key
words I'm now awaiting anytime that's
happening anything that's happening
asynchronously instead of blocking until
it's completes and I've changed the
signature of methods anything that would
would have previously been void like my
main method now returns a task anything
that returned some tea like the eggs or
the bacon now returns a task of tea so
this is really the mental model I want
everyone have when you're writing
anything that's asynchronous we all know
how to write methods and functions avoid
returning method is a method that does
homework and when that method exits that
work has been done any method that
returns some value is a method that does
some computation creates a value and
then returns that value by analogy once
I start doing something asynchronous any
method that does some work returns a
task and I can ask the task in my code
are you done yet or please continue with
this once you've finished what that task
was anything that returns a task of T is
a method that performs some calculation
and is now going to return a task object
so I can determine when it finishes and
when it has finished I can retrieve the
result from that task so just like today
in any synchronous program that you
write you create methods that perform
actions and you create functions that
compute values when you're writing an
asynchronous program what you're going
to do is write functions that return
tasks if they do some action or task of
T if they're going to do some action
that returns a value over time that's
the key concept to put in your head
anytime you work with this once you have
that now you can start composing these
things in a way that works a
synchronously because I started writing
this synchronously from the get-go I
wrote it in such a way that I'm not
really getting all the advantages I want
out of async its operating exactly as we
wanted to have it run and I'm awaiting
each one of those tasks and not doing
anything else while it happens I can I
can fix that I'm gonna now I'm just
going to change these well we'll make
this a task of eggs and I will rename
this as my eggs task now I don't want
that oh wait so now that's now a
variable and object that is that task
that represents that work this will now
continue after I've started it and I
will start working on the next
ask okay because the eggs are in the pan
they're cooking away I can be doing
something else so we'll make that same
refactoring here on the other
asynchronous tasks
now before I can apply the butter and
apply the jam it's got to come out of
the toaster right I mean I suppose I
could put the butter in the toaster but
that might not end well so I'm gonna
right here I'm just gonna await the
toast it's a my toast is oh wait the
toast ask
great and now before my breakfast is
ready
I need to have all those tasks finish so
I'm just going to go await task dot went
all and I made some eggs so I've got my
eggs task
I made the bacon and I should even
though it's should be I'm gonna await
the toast task again just to be explicit
about it now I should probably move
these because I'll leave those them in
there at the moment just this will be
illustrative as to what our next step is
so now what I've done is I've started
these tasks I'm cashing those tasks
variables right so it's going it's a
it's the thing that's going to return
eggs or bacon when it's done and until
then it's a task that's running and I'm
going to await it at the end that's when
I take stuff out of the pan so now if I
run this I'm going to say yep yep okay
I've got stuff going look at that the
stuffs already in toaster it's in the
bacon in the pan I'm flipping a little
the bacon over the OJ is already ready
put the eggs in the plate okay
everything's ready that's nice and
notice how it executed faster I didn't
synchronously wait for each one of those
things to finish okay that's pretty good
this code now has a little bit of
ugliness to it though because well I'm
saying that the eggs and bacon already
as soon as I started the tasks they're
not really done then and I don't like
that extra weight to do the toast thing
where I put the toast in it comes back
up it's now in this method I had to
await it separately and no that's not
what I want at all so let's take these
three lines right here and I'm gonna put
them in a local function
and that's going to return just a task
you know if your host
goes with butter and jam and that's
going to take any task of toast
and now if I put those lines in this
local method it's called my bread
toasting because that'll be a good name
for that okay so now if we look at this
and then we can return our toast now
that's just creating a function that
composes tasks one of the things that
we've used the phrase we've used often
here is don't compose sink over a sink
when I had that a weight up above and I
said okay stop everything wait for the
toast and then do this this code I was
bringing that back that tasks back up
and then I was doing some more work with
it and that extra work was synchronous
and about three minutes ago I said we
can think of our composition with
asynchronous programs the same way we
think of it as how we would do it with
synchronous programs I did some work and
now I'm doing some more work that
initial work means a function call and
then when I'm doing some more work
that's what happens after that function
call and that can be in its own function
that's what I've done right here I take
in this task of toast where my toast is
is in the toaster and the thing that
happens later which is technically
referred to as a continuation I put that
in the same method so now what I've done
is I have composed a task so my input
here is a task that when it's finished
I'm going to do some more work so
because what came in was asynchronous
this is now an asynchronous method and
therefore must return a task in this
case it's a task of toast so now up here
we're going to call this and here now my
toast task is just this dot
and I said toast with butter and jam
right intellisense is in my way hello I
can't I should if I make that an
extension method I could do that
and here as I call it now becomes kind
of obvious what I'm doing I'm starting a
task and then I'm passing that task to
another function to say you know when
that first task finishes do some other
things and when you do those other
things then return now different toast
it's now got butter and jam right that's
programming with composition of tasks
all I have to do once I start to see
this pattern is realize that I just need
to move some code around and put it into
methods that will return a task anytime
you see this pattern that says do these
things and when that finishes do some
other stuff that's writing a couple
asynchronous functions just like right
now you would say well step one is this
step two is this step three is that that
might be three method calls same basic
concept but now we're just carrying
along some extra information in the form
of a task okay so this male model start
to make more sense we start to see this
so now let's I'm gonna do the same thing
with my eggs and bacon being ready but
I'm gonna do it in a different way
because I already have some methods down
here since I had a method that was
making my eggs I'm just going to put the
eggs already down here inside that
method because I already am doing some
composition but I could do the same
thing by taking the eggs and the bacon
and putting it putting it in a local
function to do more work there and any
of these can be put together put
together in different ways so at any one
of these await points basically what
you're doing is saying after this thing
finishes then executes the continuation
it's in the same method the task will
finish when all of those things are done
if it's in different methods you'll pass
the task in and retrieve a new task out
it's done when all those things are
finished
cool now if I run this I think we get a
pretty good mental model as to how this
is gonna work call dr. Dada Dada Dada
pouring coffee I put stuff in and now
you can see his things finish I've
already put the butter and jam on the
toast put the eggs in the plate the eggs
already flipped the bacon the second
part of the bacon is done breakfast is
ready yes and that's now all the
complexity you really need to make this
work I started three different tasks
those are composed of subtasks and then
when those tasks are finished my
breakfast is ready it sounds a lot like
what we do every day and if you look at
this code now and this is where the
syntax is is rather pleasant and we hope
leads to an understanding once you start
to really see and get this mental model
and we explain it better this still
reads the way we would communicate to
another person how to make the breakfast
start from here start moving this
through and then when all those things
are done everything's ready
simple right we hope now there's a few
things because of the age of the API and
because it was built on top of some
things that came before that make this a
little bit nastier there's a couple
things that we're going to work with all
right so as we said cooking bread
synchronously it looks pretty much like
this we went to and we changed it and
how it looks a little bit like this
change the name I think in the slide
from what I did here but pretty much the
same kind of thing the same logic is
still there as I read it now a couple of
the things that people run into a lot
before I get to async streams that are
probably the most common questions we
get and it is where I think in every
higher-level language almost anything we
do any abstraction we do at some point
in time at some point you get far enough
into it that the abstraction least a
little bit when we're dealing with async
and await in tasks the place that leaks
is where we get to dealing with a
synchronization context or the context
that code runs on so you'll see things
and we do this in our Docs and we
explain where we also will say something
like continue configure await false and
we say you should do this but a lot of
times we don't really say why that well
and here's where the abstraction kind of
hurts for the reason this doesn't
compile is configure await actually
returns a different kind of a way table
than a task so if I were just to make
this a var because it's it's actually an
i async await able I think or a
configure await context and I probably
have to change that as well
and in this application it's a console
application so I don't really need to do
anything with configure wait and here's
where there's times where you need to do
it there's times when you don't so a
common misconception is that a
synchronization context equates to a
threat the reality is that a
thread except when it doesn't and the
reason is there are special contexts and
that have exactly one thread in
particular a UI context so if you are
writing a Windows desktop program WPF
program WinForms UWP xamarin there is
one thread that is allowed to update
controls on the screen that UI thread so
if you are running in the
synchronization context that is allowed
to work with the UI there is exactly one
thread that is in that context and if
your continuations what's actually
happening under the covers here which is
why we say this is a part of the
abstraction that leaks a little bit is
there's going to be effectively some
things that get hooked up and the
compiler creates some gnarly code that
says do this and then hook up an event
so that after this thing finishes now do
the rest of this stuff and that event by
default is going to be on the same
context where the work started okay in
the case of the UI and a UI application
that will mean on the same thread
because there is only one thread in that
context so if this were a windowed
program my tasks would kind of stop and
pause in order to switch to execute the
code when something else finished and
then would come back if any of these
were long-running cpu-bound applications
that would kind of be a jerky experience
for users and the way you can avoid that
is then you say configure await false
which means the continuation can run in
another contact
and that other context might be a
background thread might be a thread pull
thread and then when it comes back up to
the UI we're gonna continue at the UI
level in the same you back in the UI
context and then we'll be back on the
only thread that can manipulate the UI
so that's a one spot where it leaks if
you're in a writing and asp.net or
asp.net core application all of your
controllers are everything that's
handling a request is on a thread pool
thread the thread pool has more than one
thread and so the name thread pool as
opposed to thread so when you're in that
context continuing on the same context
may very well mean a different thread in
fact in all likelihood it almost
certainly means a different thread in
any production scale application but it
will be another thread in the same
context because it will be in the thread
pool okay so that's a bit of a
long-winded explanation so what's the
guidance and why did we pick the default
that is going to continue on the same
you know configure wait if I don't put
anything it's like you put configure
await true why did we make that to
default if we tell everybody doing
libraries and configure await false well
the reason is configure await true or
not doing anything your code will always
work correctly you may in certain
situations lose a little bit of
responsiveness particularly at the UI
level configure await false if you know
what you're doing in the library and you
know that the continuation can execute
anywhere and you're not taking in a
delegate which might actually be
modifying the UI or doing something else
so it could be bad you can switch
contexts and it won't hurt so configure
await false means your library is going
to be more responsive however if you
don't know exactly what's going on and
you can't correctly make some of those
assumptions configure await false means
your app might crash because somebody
using it might update the UI and be in
the wrong car
text you might deadlock or you might get
race conditions
hence the default is the same as
configure away true because it will
always work and not putting it in
doesn't cause really bad stuff I don't
have a good demo for that with breakfast
so I'm going to be working on that as we
update the Docs and that's probably the
single biggest bit the key thing of this
whole simulation that I want people to
remember and to build this mental model
of working with async is just like with
every bit of code you write you break
things up into methods those methods are
actions that return void or return some
value that they computed when you move
that code in an asynchronous processing
model at at a method that does some work
returns a map a task and you use the
task to determine when that work
finished and you always almost always
want to know when the tasks finished a
method that does some work in computes
of value returns a task of T so you ask
the task is it done yet and you retrieve
the value then you get the computation
that was done asynchronously okay so I'm
going to load up a second solution and
as that loads yeah we can say these
we'll talk a little bit about async
streams
so async streams now we're going to
introduce three new interfaces that if
you squint close one eye and look at are
going to look amazingly familiar first
in system that collection is not generic
we are going to have I a sync enumerable
that looks a lot like ienumerable
the difference is the method instead of
being called get the numerator is called
get a sinc enumerator and it implements
I a sinc enumerator instead of I
enumerator and if we look at this Ayase
and kanuma Reiter it looks a lot like
ienumerator of T the difference current
looks exactly the same I'm just going to
get a T move next async looks a lot like
move next remember what I said about
that mental model instead of returning a
bool it's going to return a task that
will tell you when it's done
and then the bool you can retrieve from
the task instead of tasks it's using
value tasks which behaves the same way
as tasks but isn't optimisation value
task is a struct task is a class for
something like enumerate enlarge
collections we can reuse memory and do a
lot fewer allocations by making it a
struct and then if you notice I a sync
enumerator like ienumerator implement
something that looks a little bit like
eye disposable but here's I a sync
disposable and if you look at ia sync
disposable you can screw into a little
bit and go that looks a lot like eye
disposable it has one method instead of
disposed it's called dispose async and
instead of returning void it returns
value tasks same mental model that was
just going through within this whole
earlier program about making a breakfast
asynchronously something that was void
now returns a task there we go so let's
look at where we think this is really a
cool thing so I'm going to go around
some of the code that's here and talk
mostly about the asynchronous parts
so everything we do for Dax is open
source on github and one of the things
that we do sometimes is we want to look
at new issues as they come in and see
what's going on so here I have this
thing I'm going to run a page query
which is using the github graph QL
library and the reason I picked graph QL
is graph QL is a very nice paging
library and then I'm when it comes back
and this thing is going to be async I'm
going to print out each one of the
issues so let's look at how this is
implemented I'm returning a task of
ienumerable of J token so I'm using the
Newton soft JSON library that's already
ugly task of ienumerable of J token whoa
I'm gonna create a request and then when
I get each one of those requests back
after the I'm going to wait here to go
make the web request and then when it
comes back I'm gonna parse the results
print stuff out a couple fields in the
response are gonna tell me if there are
more pages and then give me a cursor so
I can get the next page so I'm going to
stuff those back in and then I'm going
to run the query again until I get all
the pages that I asked for I'm stopping
at 10 just because this is a rather
large repo so if you look at the
structure of this code I'm gonna make a
request put data into an array see that
there's more pages make another request
add more data to that array make another
request add more data that array until
I've requested as much as I want then
send the whole thing back and let the
caller enumerate it I picked an overload
of this that implements an I progress
API so that can print out a message when
each packet comes back and it looks like
I disconnected from the speaker Wi-Fi so
before I run this we will get back
internet connection because this demo
doesn't work real well without an
Internet
yes so now when I run it the way it
works as I said this kind of before in a
world before async streams after it
builds you can see we're gonna make a
request now we're pausing and we should
get dated soon one hopes there we go so
now I've got 25 issues now I got 50 and
you can see each page is coming back and
then once I get my 10 pages there's the
last 100 or 250 issues that we've
received I like the fact that the last
one there I said async void bag which is
true okay so there it came back nice
stuff
now if this were production and in
today's world if I really wanted to
access that data as it came back I would
have to do some things like have that I
progress start to return the ienumerable
and keep track of who's a numerating it
and make sure I don't rewrite memory and
so on and a big critique of this program
right now is this array it has to hold
all the results so if I'm doing a whole
lot of work like say it's an ml program
where I'm getting a hundred million data
points that's a lot of memory allocated
if I'm going to stream through it so
let's change this so let's make this
doing something to start retrieving
these immediately so let's change all of
this and just retrieve an i async
enumerable
there we go that's cool and now down
here the nice things I can do is I can
delete that array because I don't really
need to keep track of all that stuff
that's just kind of I don't want to
allocate all that memory and keep having
it grow all over the place and then when
this comes back
AHA instead of this I'm not going to do
that because I don't need to merge
things but what I can do is for each J
object and notice it was it is going to
be issues of results some nodes
and yield return issue right make sure I
got that right
as well make sure I got that variable
name right Oh Jerry yeah for it to lead
to that code I meant to just move it
yeah that was exactly what I wanted okay
and now because this isn't icing I a
sink enumerable I'm gonna skip this
progress reporting bit and because I now
yield returning I can remove the
returned since I'm skipping the progress
well and get rid of that last last
argument because I don't really need it
and now here aha to iterate this instead
of here this a weight issue in each
issues I'm just going to grab this part
of the code and instead of issues I'm
just going to put it right there close
bracket don't need this and I'm getting
a red squiggle there because I need to
await for each it cool okay so the code
looks really just like enumerate in a
sequence but now I've just added this a
weight in front of the for each to say
yeah this is an async strain it's going
to get data back when it gets data back
and down below instead of ienumerable
I've just said I a sink and numerable
and I can put some weights in there each
time I need to get a new page awesome
and now what I really love about this
feature and the things we can do with it
is watch what happens differently now as
I run this version I got a chunk of data
and imma numerating it and then I get
another chunk of data and imma
numerating it and so on and so forth
okay I just run that one more time to
really really drive that home notice how
we're going to get it's going to pause
it makes that first request boom boom
okay and this is part of why this
interface is implemented the way it is I
a sync innumerable return something that
is going to hand you will be able to
retrieve the next element and when it's
available and if the next element is
already in memory or already retrieved
from your asynchronous data source
you'll be able to get that immediately
and just continue to enumerate that's
why I get that after that first pause
you see 25 issues come out and then
there's a pause at some point you'll hit
a page boundary where you need to make
the next request to get the next hunk of
data and at that time it's asynchronous
inside the implementation you'll be able
to see that detail right up here I'm
making a request to a web service I'm
getting some data back and down here or
I'm letting you enumerate the sequence
I'm just gonna yield return however many
have downloaded if I change the page
size here from 25 to 50 the chunks would
be bigger changed it to 10 it would be
smaller here where I'm enumerated and
iterating it it doesn't matter I'm
iterating the sequence you'll get the
next element immediately if it's already
downloaded but without changing anything
that you're doing here to enumerate the
sequence when the source has to do some
asynchronous work to get the next piece
of data the source will enumerate or
we'll go asynchronous you'll have to
await here and then get the next one the
only part I didn't demonstrate here is
if I moved my github client object down
into this method it would be disposed
after the weight finishes another couple
bits and nice things here I wouldn't
have to implement cancellation and
cancellation stores in something like
this how do I cancel and not make more
requests just stop a numerate in the
sequence I would not make another robe
request because if I look at the
implementation here
let's say I stopped after the first ten
issues came back that yield for each
would return the first 10 there stay
still 15 in this instance in memory and
I don't loop back up to the next part of
the loop and make another request
so cancellation is automatic I just
stopped reading from the async stream
and then up here it's currently in main
but if this were like somewhere in a
service layer if I stop for reaching
this and that the return of run paged
query once that goes out of scope it's
going to get disposed of and any
connections would automatically get
closed so the mental model now it's just
like enumerated of synchronous sequence
and the compiler is going to generate
the code to automatically cancel if you
stop a numerating right just because you
won't make any more asynchronous
requests and automatically clean up
after the enumerable goes out of scope
or after the enumerator goes out of
scope awesome
I could say that all the time call
alright
so again reviewing key point is you
start to play with this feature if you
just squint a little bit it looks just
like what you're using today there you
go
so it should be really familiar and
generating a sequence it's going to look
a lot like what you do today except
instead of returning an ienumerable you
return an eye a sync innumerable add the
async modifier on the method and you can
use awaits inside the code that's going
to generate the sequence and with that
we've worked through those cool last a
little bit I want to talk about kind of
shifting gears a bit is in the last
months the dotnet foundation has now
opened and announced open membership
okay what this really is is dotnet kind
of growing up and trying to have more of
a stake for those people like all of you
who paid to come to a conference to
learn more things and when in this room
because you want to learn more about
dotnet to have your own professional
organization that net Foundation has I
think 287 projects was the last number I
saw some of them are projects that
started at Microsoft
many of them are all community driven
projects if you have participated in any
of those projects whether that's writing
issues on any of our repos contributing
to our Docs submitted PRS either to one
of the Microsoft repos or to xunit or to
any of the projects that you work with
you can become a member and notice I
said if you've contributed issues and
participated in discussions you don't
have to have written a pull request if
you go to this dotnet foundation.org
slash become a member you can read all
the details think of it as your
professional organization if you care
about the future of dotnet and
direction this is the organization
that's going to be setting that
direction board elections will be next
month so joining now means you would
participate and vote on the board by
laws have been changed so that any
corporate member can have no more than
two people on the board so only two
microsoft employees at most will be on
this Beth masse it's been announced has
been the one board seat Microsoft gets
to appoint one anyone else who wants to
run if you are a member you can also run
for the board all the information is
once again on some links it will be able
to become a member
think of it as your professional Society
professional organization for dotnet if
you are interested please please
consider it any questions yes start
there
when when does a task start executing in
c-sharp a task starts executing as soon
as you call the code
that's in that method it will execute up
to the first await and it will only go
asynchronous once it hits the first a
weight that's awaiting a non completed
task so in c-sharp all tasks start
running
I don't think tax to do to start it to
create a task but then start it later
okay and so I hand go up somewhere over
here I thought yes so what was the
motivation of adding two keywords to
have a sink and a weight in order to
split those two um I may defer to you on
that one
come on up to the mic I think there's
one
I thought I was done sorry is that one
honest you guys asking I bet they can do
that back there hello yes yes okay so
that was of course a discussion point
shoot what why do we have two key words
can't we just recognize that there's an
a wait in the method for instance and
then a reason that it's async and we
actually did make that choice for
iterators where we recognized as a yield
keyword and we realized that this method
has to be an iterator we decided that we
didn't want to do that because the the
await can be really deeply buried in
weight expression is an expression it
can be really deeply inside some coding
to be hard to just look at a piece of
code and see this and I wait in there
whereas the yield is the statement so
it's a little more it's a little more
visible at least and I also think we
probably made a mistake with the yield I
think we should have had a keyword for
the iterators as well so the async is
primarily there to make it clear that
this is an async method it also helps
with some compiled technical things of
avoiding ambiguity and because the
weight wasn't a keyword all the time
people could have that things that were
called a weight they'd have a you know
method or variable called a weight and
we would we had to kind of respect that
kind of code but the async keyword is
new so whenever you have a sink we know
that a weight inside isn't is the
keyword away somebody's declared a
weight mm-hmm does that explain yeah
cool I'll run back down any others
that's right there yeah is it redundant
to write a sink and then tasks no
probably the quickest way to explain it
is it's again if we look at the time
yeah here in c-sharp 7.2 a feature got
snuck in that was called generalized
async return types and one of those is
actually you can see an example of both
of the things where that's important
here if you notice I a sink disposable
to suppose a sink returns a value tasks
and here this also returns a value task
of
of a bull and the reason for that in
this instance to use value tasks is
because there's some optimizations that
can be made in some memory allocations
that we don't need for that so the
compiler now recognizes that an async
method doesn't have to return a task it
has to return something that has the
right pattern and the right methods so
that it can be awaited okay
the second reason for that is if you
look at IA sync a numerator or IA sync
innumerable itself we can await that
because we recognize that pattern and
then this was right there i thought yeah
why do we have tests that wait tasks
that result get a waiter and get result
probably mostly historical there were
times when you needed to do something
synchronous at some point bubble up to
it so it's there but I would I would
recommend moving forward that that would
probably be a Coatesville anytime I see
a dot wait or a dot result like I
started with in the async breakfast when
I saw a test out the way dot wait yeah I
would really try to avoid that yeah I
think I know I am pretty sure that
there's a project nougat project called
dotnet analyzers that I think finds that
and it will give you if you install that
analyzing your project it will give you
analyzer warnings if someone does those
I can look that up for you after as we
get done one last question and then I
will make sure the next person gets up
in it okay way back there oh dear
why does it move next a sink take a
cancellation token because it really
doesn't need one all I have to do to
cancel this is don't ask for it I could
so the question is the assertion was I
could ask for and then later decide I
could cancel it if we look at the code
that I wrote here let's say you've asked
for the first 25 and now you've asked
for the 26th element so I have nothing
here in this yield return I'm going to
go to the issues return plus equals
whatever come back up here there's more
pages and I'm going to make a web
request so before it actually awaits
I've sent that packet right so I've made
that asynchronous request so cancel at
that point is meaningless until it comes
back because the rest of this is gonna
execute anyway okay so one of the things
that we said earlier in the current
model is that if you support
cancellation cancellation should
actually mean that you can cancel it
once I've already made the web request
it's already out there on another
machine so cancel really doesn't do
anything other than throwing away the
results when they get back okay good
question though at this point I'm gonna
make sure the next person can set up but
I will be more than happy to take
questions individually up here I want to
thank you for all of your time and
please if you like this analogy please
give me feedback on that either here on
Twitter or if you look at the repo
create issues because I think this is a
has been a good way to explain the
concepts and that's one of the things
I'm going to be doing in terms of
reworking the docs thank you very much
for your time
you